good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight as you doubtless know
the most controversial document in
America remains totally mysterious it's
only four pages long it is classified
that means while many are talking about
it and they are virtually nobody has
actually read it it's a memo is prepared
by the House Intelligence Committee and
apparently it describes surveillance of
American citizens in this country by our
own intelligence and law enforcement
agencies several Republicans who have
seen the documents say it exposes
massive and terrifying abuses of our
civil liberties presumably committed for
political gain they say the memo shows
how the Obama administration used the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act
not to protect this country from foreign
threats like terror which is its purpose
but to spy on rival campaigns the Trump
campaign in particular and to create a
pretext for the current Independent
Counsel investigation the one that has
mesmerised our political class and all
but paralyzed our government going on
over a year even today the president was
responding to questions about it watch
when you believe Robert clearly I own I
own a repeat for the purposes of making
sure yet one more quick one do you think
Robert Miller will be fair to you in
this larger investigation we're gonna
find out and everybody says no collusion
there's no collusion but now they're
saying oh well did he fight back you
fight back yes sir we fight back Johnson
they fight back oh it's obstruction so
here's the thing I hope so
so how do you define collusion and Matt
gasps this earlier during the briefing
to Sarah but now you're gonna define it
for me okay but I can tell you there's
no collusion I couldn't have cared less
about Russians having to do with my
campaign so all we talk about in
Washington pretty much so if it turns
out that this whole investigation is a
politically motivated sham
that'll be newsworthy in the words of
one sitting member of Congress quote
when this memo comes out people will go
to jail now those are strong words is
the memo that damning honestly we don't
know we have no idea like pretty much
everyone else in Washington we haven't
read a single word of it but we
certainly take the idea seriously and
why wouldn't we the most a stabilizing
thing any government can do is use law
enforcement as a political weapon that's
when the police become the secret police
and suddenly are no longer living in a
free country it happens all the time in
other places our founders were worried
about that happening here and the rest
of us ought to be worried too
a rogue FBI is a far bigger threat to
you and your family than any buffoonish
tweet from The Oval Office it actually
matters it could wreck everything we've
built here so this is not a story we
ought to ignore the public deserves to
know needs to know what's in that memo
this is our government we have a right
to know if it's representing us or if
it's lying to our faces
if there's corruption expose that
corruption transparency is the only
antidote now you think everyone would
agree with that sentiment pretty
commonplace and by the way when you
think about it what exactly is the
counter-argument against that
secrecy is good people shouldn't know if
their government is corrupt more
darkness and deception please even in
Washington you can't say those things
out loud though many would like to trust
me
so instead Democrats on the hill and
there many handmaidens in the media have
a new argument you're not allowed to
know what's in that memo because Russia
seriously that is the case they are now
making as if yesterday Senator Dianne
Feinstein in congressman Adam Schiff
Democrats both from the state of
California are warning that if you want
to read that document that memo which by
the way was prepared by the US
government for American lawmakers you
are somehow in league with the Vladimir
Putin regime yesterday those two sent a
letter to the CEOs of Facebook and
Twitter claiming that calls to release
the memo are quote an ongoing attack by
the Russian government through Kremlin
linked social media actors directly
acting to intervene and influence our
democratic process end quote
got that anyone asking for more
transparency from this government and
that would include elected members of
Congress and this show among others
anyone who's doing that is participating
in a foreign propaganda campaign that
hurts America in other words they're
traitors the implication of ship--and
Feinstein's letter is that twitter and
facebook ought to do something to help
by the way quickly like I don't know
censor the accounts of anyone who wants
to see the memo you think the media
might have a big problem with all
of this for centuries the American press
has fought efforts by politicians and
those in power to hide unflattering
information about themselves that was
noble work is the reason that the press
is mentioned in the First Amendment but
they're not doing that anymore on
television today
you heard famous anchors make the
opposite case they suggested that calls
to release the memo are simply tactics
by right-wing crazies and Vladimir Putin
to undermine America because they're
unpatriotic
and that's what you knew it was over the
long and worthy tradition of journalists
as watchdogs holding the powerful to
account
turns out the journalists have switched
teams there with the powerful now they'd
like you to shut the hell up